while we're all waiting for the pool to fill up
I thought I would just quickly
renovate the kitchen
and one of my specialties is
gaslighting myself into believing that a
project's gonna be quicker
and easier than it turns out to be
and honestly if I didn't have that blind
delusional faith driving me each day
I probably wouldn't attempt anything
and the plan here is just to give her a wee facelift
because functionally there's nothing wrong with her
but aesthetically it's not for me
we started the same way we did the pool really
by removing all of the old tiles
and then the boys from architectural stone
came and removed the old benchtops
and installed the new ones
I chose a beautiful piece of Dekton from Cosentino
which I'll show you soon
before the sink and the tap went in
and now the hard work really begins
because I basically wanna tile as much of the kitchen as
as humanly possible
if you're new here
we've spent the last year and a half restoring our beautiful
but kind of beat up mid century home
and we've tackled a few projects that involve tiling
and I have surprised myself with how much I enjoy doing it
I mixed up some tile adhesive
which is much like baking a cake except
you know
a lot easier
popped up the tile trim and then notched the adhesive
as if I actually know what I'm doing
and then I got to work positioning the tiles
and these are the Kreuz tiles in Matte White
which is a porcelain Japanese Kitkat tile
from TileSpace
one thing I love about these tiles
aside from how cute they are
is that they come with a mesh backing so they're so easy to apply
so much easier than the pool tiles that had
that adhesive on the front
I have a bit of a crazy vision with where and
how I want these tiles placed
and at this point I'm feeling kinda nervous
only because I want them kind of everywhere
and I hope it's not gonna be too much
but the vision for this project is just to lighten and brighten
The natural light in here already isn't great
but having all of those dark finishes
just made it feel a lot dingier than it needed to be
if you've seen any of my other room renovations
you will know I love using colour
but for the kitchen I wanna go for
clean natural and textured
we took the tiles right to the ceiling
but then this extractor fan was really getting to me to be honest
and some people might like this look
it's not terrible I suppose
but for me I just fkn hate looking at it
and I am very fortunate to be married to a
man who's easily bribed
once I corrupted him he built me a box
added some moulding so it seamlessly
blended with the ceiling and tiled it
I would have done it myself
but the ceilings are actually really high
and I said I couldn't reach, so..
he cut some slits into each side for ventilation
and then it was time to grout
which was terrifying
I started with a sample of light grout
but we kinda lost the shape and the impact of the tile
and it made them throw yellow
which just looked like stained teeth
if I'm honest
I never actually thought I'd be a dark grout girly
but here we are and I think it was the move
and I'm so sorry but full reveal in the next part